[Música]
economía en directo américa de france 24
ya está conmigo y listo en el estudio
flores hurtado jorge félix lunes
iniciamos semana siguiendo de cerca las
tensiones en europa el este a nivel
político para a nivel económico le
pregunto a las implicaciones que traería
un conflicto y futuras sanciones no
mejores así es bueno la unión europea
sobre todo para la unión europea ya que
rusia es su quinto socio comercial raúl
y el principal proveedor de energía un
análisis de bloomberg detalla que hay
cautela en europa del este- por este
conflicto el bloque de la unión europea
sería el gran perdedor con la entrada de
nuevas sanciones a rusia contrario a la
relación comercial entre eeuu y rusia
que es mínima en comparación con europa
por ejemplo el conflicto podría cortar
el suministro de gas natural en pleno
invierno que es cuando más se necesita
en europa mientras eeuu es un exportador
neto de energía la unión europea depende
de las importaciones y rusia su
principal proveedor de petróleo y gas
natural
russian representa el 26 por ciento y el
40 por ciento respectivamente de las
importaciones europeas de esos
hidrocarburos economistas de jpmorgan
vieron que un aumento del precio del
petróleo podría afectar al crecimiento y
estimular la inflación aunque para rusia
también hay muchos juegos raúl la unión
europea es el mayor socio comercial de
rusia y el destino del 38% el total de
sus exportaciones según datos de la
comisión europea también afectaría los
lazos financieros lo que dejaría a moscú
aislado del sistema financiero mundial
jorge y nos quedamos en europea porque
hay datos del gasto para amortiguar este
precio de la energía jorge así es un
informe de la comisión europea detalla
que los países del bloque han gastado
aproximadamente 21 mil millones de euros
para contener la crisis de precios la
comisaria europea de energía matriz
simpson insistió en que la caja de
herramientas que propuso la comisión
europea para hacer frente a la carestía
energética sigue siendo una referencia
para que los países los tengan cierto
margen de maniobra pero hay resistencia
para promover una reforma del mercado
eléctrico españa francia e italia
reclaman a la comisión medidas
extraordinarias para hacer frente a una
escalada de precios entre ellas limitar
el precio máximo del kilovatio que pagan
los consumidores pero alemania y países
bajos
se ponen a tocar los mercados porque
creen que desincentivaría la competencia
en el último año los precios del gas y
la electricidad en europa crecieron casi
en 500% la agencia internacional de la
energía acusa a rusia de enviar un
tercio menos del gas que podría y señala
la empresa rusa gazprom de mantener bajo
mínimo sus depósitos jorge es que esta
atención que sigue en europa del s
influyendo en los precios del petróleo
internacional porque bueno la
preocupación por la interrupción del
suministro en por este conflicto que se
vive en europa del este así como el
aumento de las tensiones en medio
oriente podrían presionar los precios es
del mercado el crudo brent subió 31
centavos para llegar a los 88 20 dólares
el barril mientras el crudo
estadounidense west texas ganó 21
centavos para alcanzar los 85 35 dólares
el barril las tensiones en ucrania
llevan meses en aumento luego de que
rusia concentrar a miles de soldados
cerca de sus fronteras los mercados
energéticos se podrían ver afectados y
las tensiones se convierten en un
conflicto hippie morgan aseguró que las
tensiones podrían provocar un pico
importante en los precios del petróleo a
corto plazo en medio oriente los
emiratos árabes unidos interceptaron y
destruyeron este lunes dos misiles
balísticos lanzados por los sutiles la
semana pasada también se registraron
algunos ataques que tuvieron su
incidencia en los precios de los
mercados internacionales esta es la
quinta semana consecutiva de aumentos en
los precios del petróleo que ha ganado
alrededor de un 2 por ciento hasta
alcanzar a raúl su máximo desde octubre
de 2014 y ante todo esto que está
ocurriendo por allá jorge como están los
indicadores entonces de europa y asia
bueno vamos a arrancar con asia el
índice nikkei de japón cerró en positivo
ya que los inversores compraron acciones
baratas después de que los futuros de
las acciones de eeuu subieran y en
europa las acciones cayeron por los
temores de un posible ataque ruso a
ucrania ya que el departamento de estado
de eeuu retiró a los familiares de su
personal de la embajada en kiev cifra el
día sobre bueno tiene que ver con el bit
con raúl al bitcoin cayó hoy más de un
7% y alcanzó su nivel más bajo en seis
meses esto por el temor de un ataque
ruso contra ucrania que provocó una
venta masiva de los activos de mayor
riesgo a nivel la famosa cripto moneda
ahora cotiza en 33 mil 650 dólares
aproximadamente y acumula pérdida de más
del 50 por ciento desde su máximo
histórico de 69 mil dólares que llegó en
noviembre pasado cuanto ahora ha perdido
entonces el presidente del ebook él pues
no creo que fue una muy buena inversión
ojalá eso se recupere no necesariamente
el presidente porque recordar que es el
dinero ahí pública así que la raíz como
tal así de jorge gracias entonces por
toda la información económica nos vemos
más adelante nosotros vamos a nuestro
reportaje al día
[Música]